[Music]
there is an update
oh good in the brian laundry situation
my bowl
i don't even know who that is yeah yeah
yeah gabby potatoes murderer
thank you thank you thank there it is uh
there was a notebook confession
from him wow what do you mean like he
carried a little journal yep so brian
lodge said he wanted to take away gabby
patio's pain in a journal entry written
before he killed himself
laundry and his fiancee petito had been
driving around national parks in the u.s
just catch people up in their van last
august all the while documenting their
trip on social media and there were
travel vloggers after petito's family
didn't hear from the 22 year old for a
couple of weeks they reported her
missing on september 11th and her
disappearance ended up becoming very
viral
laundry then disappeared on september
14th and petito's body was discovered on
the 19th on the edge of wyoming's grand
teton national park which the couple had
visited
a huge manhunt hunt culminated in the
unearthing of laundry's remains on the
october 20th in the carlton reserve
wilderness park near the laundry's home
along with the 23 year old's remains
were a revolver a backpack and a
notebook let me show a photo
i googled grand teton national park it's
beautiful have you been there no i want
to where is it wyoming whoa wyoming is
just this
is a notebook with a picture it's got
some nice penmanship it does actually
it's very neat i thought people that
were like younger than us didn't know
how to write cursive that's not cursive
that's not christmas it's like
italicized a little bit all right
he doesn't buy it
he's all right he checks out
he's like whatever i'm not gonna die on
this hill whatever oh my god photos of
the notebook first published uh your
show laundry confessing to gabby's
killing which he said he did out of
mercy
quote
that's a weird way to think of it quote
i thought it was merciful that it was
what she wanted but i see now all the
mistakes i made i panicked i was in
shock he went on to just also beating
her ass too yeah stupid was that exactly
what had happened well i think that's
what the uh
the police port said right they said
that she hit him well i think it was
just one incident oh was it wasn't she
hitting him in the van they were all
fighting with each other and i heard
that he she would hit him but yeah they
were they were fighting a lot but then
the cops actually
she they had said that she had hit like
they was admitted so that was the point
that they should have split them up but
they did yeah
what did the autopsy say about her
actual death strangulation i think
yeah he like choked her out crazy
oh geez which is wild he went on to
describe her death as an unexpected
tragedy claiming gabby got injured one
night as they tried to cross a stream
he said she had a small bump on her
forehead that eventually got larger as
well as other injuries
and she was begging for an end to her
pain oh bro he's [ __ ] he's nuts
he added
quote from the moment i decided took her
pain away i knew i couldn't go on
without her
laundry finished the journal entry by
expressing his hope that animals in the
carlton reserve would tear him apart
he wrote i am ending my life not because
of a fear of punishment but rather
because i can't stand to live another
day without her it just sounds like they
got into an argument he freaked out got
impulsive and killed her strangled her
to death and then he had to imagine a
different scenario so he could live with
himself and then he killed himself they
already certified this journal as real
evidence like they know that some
other random person didn't just throw it
in there after the finding out about the
case or something because i think they
found it on him because he he was found
dead in the uh they found his body in
like a swamp or something right yeah oh
it was on his head i think it was
it's probably crazy that they just
released it now you know that is good
paper impact because it didn't like get
soaked up nope no smudges
so let's say uh just in the mind right
of joe because we love that well you try
i'm gonna come on man i'm not gonna kill
nobody like that that i love i kill a
lot of other people but not people on
that let's say you strangled her in a
crime of passion and now you had to come
up with another reason for why it
happened why
man she was a [ __ ] bro
she was tripping all the time that's the
reason you're going to jail no but
people will understand them oh yeah
you're right you're right
they'll understand right away with no
other details no other context justice
okay
i i think that i'd have to do the same
thing because i wouldn't be able to live
with myself i had to create a new story
in my head i'd have to be like oh dude
you're a [ __ ] bear cane man that bear
like a bitter leg and then like she was
in pain so like dude i don't know i had
to [ __ ] throw over a cliff
where's their bear bites
your ankle no i don't know wouldn't that
be crazy if you were with someone in the
forest
and a bear actually showed up and
strangled that person instead of biting
it no one's gonna believe that you saw
what happened and you're like especially
if you swear yeah
nobody's gonna believe me he's like a
bear just grabbed her throat
on joe yeah yeah it must have been
circus beer how does he know to do that
or if like you're you guys are around a
campfire right with her
and then you you lay your gun down
and there's a chicken cuz
and throws a [ __ ] acorn it hits the
trigger and shoots her and they're like
no one's gonna believe that i i [ __ ]
did a shooter
out of everyone that's how do you try to
convince people [ __ ] squirrels
[Laughter]
the only thing you could do is replicate
it so you'd have to like get a shitload
of squirrels
a bunch of guns and drinks but then now
you're gonna be admitted to a [ __ ]
mental hospital exactly but and they're
like you just trained the squirrels to
kill her that's the risk that's it
and it's gonna be like your own dog that
doesn't do tricks when you need it to
you're like i swear to god this happened
it's [ __ ] why don't you [ __ ] do it
man why you did it earlier
[Laughter]
yeah
that's what would be so funny about
outlandish murders and then like dude if
they really were like because i'm sure
there's some some of them are out there
right yeah there's gotta be yeah there's
gotta be bear out there to strike the
[ __ ] out of every animal and then just
seize a person
but it says she died of strangulation
like just [ __ ] with an object or with
hands
or does it with the object with hands
you know i don't know i don't know were
there bear claws on the neck
yeah you know what not not the autopsy i
read i think i would spend the rest of
my time trying to catch the bear so then
if they all look the same
you break them in for confessions tell
them what you
did yeah it says she was killed by
manual strangulation in the autopsy come
on yogi what the [ __ ] dude
all the side by strangulation of bear
yogi bear specifically
good luck getting a confession out of
that bear yeah i'm like
foreign
the bear shows up at the station by
himself
turns himself in i have a confession to
make
i was the one dang
that's pretty [ __ ] crazy it is
[ __ ] crazy so you guys want to talk
about anything else
that's such a [ __ ] childish attempt
though to like write a [ __ ] alibi
like
and just make a difference well at least
it's kind of cool right because it puts
some closure at least on the family's
part which closure that this dude was
indeed an idiot yeah yeah and crazy the
pump got bigger
that
we needed to yeah we need to get rid of
this her pain like she twisted her ankle
and it started swelling so i got a huge
rock and smashed her head with it to end
the pain like what the [ __ ] dude
i decided after i was like
it's not about the punishment i just
can't go on without her she got a bee
sting so i decided to [ __ ] nudge her
off a cliff like
that should be hella funny what if that
should be fun if you're watching like an
nba game and like a player trips and his
ankles start swelling and he just goes
[ __ ] kill me
get that guy like so extreme in the pain
within seconds he's like bro just just
do me in man i can't take it he jams his
finger he's like you killed me
when you hit your pinky toe on the
[ __ ] corner of the bed oh dude it
hurts i'm ready bro i dropped it i
dropped my phone on my [ __ ] foot the
other day i was like dude i'm gonna jump
off a [ __ ] building because it's such
a fun that's such a movie thing it's
like normally people don't sustain an
injury and then just process it and go
you know what just [ __ ] kill me bro
like that's it like that's the next
level most of the time if you if it's
that severe you're not even [ __ ]
saying anything you want to just stay
alive
you're just going into shock was there
proof of a contusion on her head
yeah several
oddly yeah was there proof of a
contusion there were several please
there were several uh brian laundry
shaped fist marks
dude it's so stupid this guy's for sure
just we were clean
and she got injured and i had to end the
pain
what if everyone's like oh man that's
what really happened crazy like who does
he expect that's going to believe that
he's a [ __ ] like first of all not to
be the most evil person in the room do
it i would have just put her back in the
[ __ ] rv and just totaled the [ __ ]
together yeah and just tried to get less
injured and not killed and then went oh
[ __ ] like you know
by the time that he had already left
this is like three days later and i left
the body that's what i mean like that
you strangle someone should put him in a
[ __ ] car seat yeah go off the cliff
or you could get her if she's already
already banged her up or no not yet yeah
she's done if you already banged her up
then you gotta go look for a snake
biter come on just buy the business
he's gotta bite and then wrap the snake
around the neck try to bite her and then
the snake bites you too
[Laughter]
he's like oh then you're just both go
kill me man
that's why that's why he committed
suicide because he was already gonna die
this one believed that i was gonna get
eaten by the forced animals that's how
stupid he is
i like that he's like that deer's here
just gonna take some time and that
[ __ ] elk will eat me
imagine how quickly you can process that
you need to find a snake after killing
someone what what snake
[Laughter]
real simple [ __ ] man
real simple [ __ ] i do the german accents
you do the [ __ ] snake accent
[Music]
you
[Music]